how's new york comedy doing since the
pandemic is it like weird or
are there a lot of like opportunities do
you still think new york is the best
comedy city in the world
um i
need to travel and
expand my horizon
i think new york is still the place
for artistic development like you were
saying
yesterday
um
i think you get uh
like challenging audiences
uh weird situations to do it i think you
do get better here
yeah but um
well you know in jiu jitsu it's like you
practice defense
on the people better than you in
practice offense on the people who are
worse than you uh-huh it's like uh
there's a you get to practice defense a
lot here
yeah it's hard place to practice offense
mm-hmm
everyone's judging you they're like what
are you doing here are you really good
at this are you like one of the many
people that are feeling at this are you
better at me
in my
or in your field
yeah like you that's the good part in
ways you know yeah it forces you to do
stuff that's like new and inventive and
always
feels like art
because then if you're not people are
going to be like oh this is not that
good yeah banking and if you yourself
are going to want to kill yourself like
yeah on on from every angle you you feel
the pressure to keep evolving yeah like
you're the you're the mood of the faces
that you see so if you see negative
faces judging you and calling you
unartistic then you're gonna feel like
that but then if you see people that are
approving of you and are like wow
you're so artistic and creative and
genius and brilliant
you're gonna be like in a better mood so
like new york will make you feel like
[ __ ] because if a lot of those faces are
negative
then it makes you feel like [ __ ] and a
lot of the comedians are also very like
arrogant in that way too
well the the
thing i'm good i'm coughing too much
um
when you see someone who
has the bad face or is in a bad mood
it's like
you
you either understand why
someone would get that sad
and if you do i think
you have the ability to take them out of
it and reach in
type of thing
but if your life is just too good to
even understand why someone would be
that sad yeah i don't think you have a
chance of
like
help or not even helping more like
connecting yeah
how shitty life is can you just like do
really good comedy and then they forget
like that their life sucks of course if
i mean
that's a very i think samurai way of
just being like you live and die by the
jokes and the writing and the quality of
the thoughts and you can do that
but
there's also like a
in the moment live
aspect to it
yeah
but can't you like
can't you in the live moment use your
jokes and ideas to create a better
situation sure
i've seen you do that i mean i think
people
learn how to make magic
and conjure magic and you do it in your
own style some people
their way of getting into that zone is
through
the the jokes that they've
tirelessly worked on some people
do the crowd work like or just like say
hello or ask
a little bit about the person try to
everyone has a system i think so you're
talking about like the art of
being in the room and responding and
talking directly to the audience
yes because it's like
there's a difference from talking to
people from talking at them
like you want to talk to people and
but you can talk to people through your
jokes absolutely and it's a lot but it's
like
i have seen
situations where i'm like this is
there's no way anything good can happen
and i've seen communions go up and kill
regardless right and that could be
through different things it could be
just like
they work that hard on their jokes and
they do their jokes or
they have that much confidence in who
they are and their ability to connect
with another person
they just talk to people and lower their
guard
and open up this possibility of a kill
you know what i mean yeah i mean
it sure helps but
i think like in
some instances people are more focused
on whether this is
a joke or not and instead of just like
even if you are telling a joke you're
still saying those words in front of a
group of people
you're still talking directly to them
um and i think like just going into like
crowd work
is um
sometimes like good
well again it's a purely
stylistic choice i think
like
um
i think
sometimes i feel like it would be weird
to not like address
i mean you can keep the wall of like
this is a show and again you can do that
like
if
if
that's the belief you have the material
that's what you the style you worked on
that that's the style you do you know
what i mean
but i feel like
even in a big show i've seen people like
just
include the crowd and adding another
whole level to it yeah well talking to
the audience is definitely a great skill
to have and i think that
i do it when
i do it when i need to
so it's like
it's like i need to feel like it's
authentic if i'm just doing it to do it
then i don't feel like good about it
yeah but that goes for your material too
you know
where it's like
like whatever conviction you have behind
it matters rather than just reciting
from your notebook you know
yeah you gotta like
you gotta convince people that what
you're saying is like
authentic mm-hmm
that's why i don't think you need to do
crowd work to get that you don't need to
do anything yeah
i feel uh it's just whatever your style
is whatever you worked on
that's what you're good at that's what
you use you know yeah if it's crowd work
if it's
like
if you have
10 different openers depending on
what the room feels like yeah i mean i
feel like
some people do more some people do less
i think that
[Music]
it's good to be able to do i think like
with me it's like brevity
and like getting to the point and saying
what i need to say
um
but yeah i mean
obviously like
some people like it but there's like a
reason why most specials are all
material
yeah
i think a special is like
kind of an ad
and it's just there to be like is what i
do when i perform live and
in a way it's the bare minimum but
that's why it's good like advertisement
because like well i just don't get that
i don't think crowdwork can ever be as
good as a good bit can i mean that's an
extreme statement there's just moments
that just come up
that are just like magic like
yeah they're good happen but they're not
like immortal
i think when you go see someone it's
like
again it's a stylistic thing depends on
the comedian like
it just seems like you're talking to
like it's like basic tricks that you can
like
break down pretty easily
like oh he's just mentioning this
different joke writing too though but
it's less of applicable for joke writing
i like both skills i think
uh like by the numbers crowd work sucks
but i also think like
like i prefer the jokes don't get me
wrong but well i don't think it's either
or they have jokes that are sort of
crowd work and again the jokes the way
you tell a bit can can if you understand
crowd work and how to do it i think
you have a better understanding of the
flow of a bit and how to do it back and
forth with it so it's a skill to work on
regardless if you're gonna like use it
use it
yeah i mean i feel like it's good to do
i think maybe that might have helped
yesterday at sesh
um well it's like a very liberal
audience yeah maybe they not like
politically but just emotionally i know
it's
emotionally liberal yeah they're just
like they don't have much they just have
ill gross
or they're like
you know
uh i'm dead
oh well
slay
queen
they're all high on edibles
yeah
they can't make too much noise it's like
goofy it's like nickelodeon energy
you you hate that
no i just bummed yesterday i guess did
you
a little bit okay
how was it compared to the stand set the
stand set was better okay i listened
back to you upset about that
no they said you didn't bomb but you
like didn't do how as well as you wanted
yeah i mean
i think i was a little hard on myself
i guess it's good to like experience any
emotion about your comedy because it's
better than not feeling anything yeah
you want to care of course
so i'm just telling myself stories
but i'm also like really um
asian and like i don't feel good about
anything
or never like satisfied
that's nice
yeah so i like have a self-talk problem
maybe
um but yeah i mean it's also
self-indulgent to just be like talking
about my set but yeah i mean it was just
i mean that's something you should be
thinking about i think it's good yeah i
mean i didn't feel great about it
you know what i did yesterday as i
worked on those jokes that bombed at the
stand you did them with sesh i did a
massage i did them at astoria where i
did really good better than any show
i've done so far in new york and it was
like the shittiest audience there's like
10 people
and it's so weird they're like real
audience members but they're all sat
like around me and
like when you know those long folding
tables uh-huh like i don't know like
business tables i don't know like garage
sale tables uh i know what you're
talking about yeah yeah it's such a
weird vibe but i did good there and that
was like my favorite setup done so far
but
yeah i mean i just did the new jokes
over again i was like the the reason why
i was sad that set isn't because
i bombed it's because i had these new
jokes and i just couldn't help myself
but to do it
i needed to do it here i don't care if i
bomb with them i need you to should have
dropped some likes and got them out of
your system or something
maybe
i mean hey if they worked at the end
then you're good
yeah
yeah like if as those jokes work if i
even find one joke in that chunk that
works it'll have been worth that bomb so
now i gotta make that bomb worth it but
honestly it wasn't even a bomb i
listened back to it i did all right
yeah i mean i think you know what you're
doing enough at this point
yeah
is this i guess i think it's
like good to squeeze every ounce of use
out of a set and even if that means
emotionally i have to torture myself
yeah to motivate myself
listen i mean that this makes sense from
what i remember of you like
because everything i think you like all
your material
is very like
gone through the the process they they
just have that on them you know what i
mean
like that's how i feel
so yeah that makes sense i'm gonna roll
because i think i was coughing because i
had no tobacco and that makes me cough
usually
so yeah
we rolled the we smoked a joint that i
got from this guy alex i think his name
is
uh he he gave me weed for free this is
it's good weed
yeah but if you're not used to smoking
it yeah
yeah i mean i think that
um
it's good to
have different styles
i just think there's a higher ceiling
when you learn how to
do the jokes
um
i don't know man
you like richard pryor
yeah
i'm just like uh there's an element of
those are all bits no no for sure
for sure i'm just saying uh
no one should you're not a like don't be
above the crowd work don't be above like
right
out of the bit
you know what i mean yeah cause that's
how it that's what it's all about at the
end of the day
you're in a room talking to people
exactly and if you're
i mean again it's really stylish
[Music]
i think it's you have to be able to do
it but i think a lot of people don't and
they still become really successful
well
then you have like like for example like
a daniel tosh
even like louie doesn't do
crowd work really yeah so maria bamford
yeah but her thing is so like already
ridiculous breaking the fourth
breaking any
uh like
conventional thing
that
i think it kind of takes care of that
yeah
so she doesn't have to do crowd work
because her bits are good enough i mean
have to what do you mean have to
like there's no have to again these are
choices
for whatever
experience you want to do yeah
but she's just i saw bill birth and
listen square garden break out of like
he got heckled
and
and he responded and it murdered so like
you know what i mean yeah like
it people respect your ability to do
that it's
yeah that's what you're doing and they
want to know that you can actually do it
yeah
you're just getting away with doing it
because of
money
every time in a room people are asking
is this the most interesting guy in the
room
can we be hearing from someone else
like why does this guy have the mic and
if it makes no sense why you have the
mic yes then they're gonna be like why
am i watching i'm just watching this
because people said it was funny yes
exactly but unless you have that ability
to convince people like yeah this is the
only way this would work out like i am
the best person in the room right now to
be doing this or someone else would be
doing it
otherwise there's literally no reason
for me to do it yeah someone else should
it's just you have to respect the
structure and the form
and the infrastructure of
the comedy
comedy club or whatever you're at
but the less you can't you have to rely
on that and the more you can just
control the room from your actual skills
the better
yeah i mean the skill is really just
talking to a lot of people
yeah and that's the trick with like
showrooms
is like you're trying to be like
i can control this room
but like an open mic you're like i
respect you as comedians i'm not trying
to be the best i'm just trying to be
unique enough so that it makes sense why
i'm up here dude one thing you said i
think you like posted it i always think
about
you said hey comedy isn't about
uh
comparing uh joke writing skills with
your peers it's about entertaining drunk
tourists
you posted that you're like meaning that
mics
are a
like a form of
costing yeah you're testing your skills
in front of your peers the people who
are pursuing the same thing yeah it is
very much
a good place to like your ability to
capture that room
like that does translate you know what i
mean yeah uh in the right settings of
course there's places where people just
it makes you write more yeah makes you
write smarter it makes you think about
what you're doing
and who you are and what you can bring
to the table and it makes you hear like
the other voices that are out there
and uh gives you a more informed
perspective about
the whole art form you learn you learn a
lot
seeing people who are better and worse
than you really
yeah
so
with
with mike's it's like if it's again the
right
setting
um
you can
well i mean
do you tell stories at all like telling
stories not really
do you want to is that something you
want to work on or like a skill you want
to develop
i mean if something interesting happens
maybe but i feel like
i don't like to think about my life in
terms of stories
interesting
yeah why
just because i'm interested more in the
forward progression and
improving
at the moment
or like
in the long term or the future it's very
douchey
i don't know i just don't do it i think
it's my culture i come from an asian
culture yeah is it not you don't tell
yourself stories you don't tell yourself
like short stories like oh today i
studied in my room for eight hours
and then uh you know jerked off and then
like you don't do that [ __ ]
you're like this is not
like the story is not that interesting
because the story is like
longer it's like i went studied and went
to college and got a job and then got a
wife and yes that's the boring story of
any culture though no not not like that
story in particular but that's the story
that i want like when i'm studying in a
room for eight hours
and that's the story you're pursuing
yeah i'm not pretty like americans are
pursuing a story of like today i went to
cinnabon i ate a cinnabon
and then i absolutely know what you mean
yeah
i remember even like uh telling my dad
this one so i was like that i just like
feel
like i'm gonna end up like going to
college getting a job getting married
and he
that sounds awful to me
but yeah it's like everything he ever
wanted you know what i mean yeah that
was what he was looking forward to when
he was a little boy wouldn't that be
nice if we had that if we had like a
lifestyle well you had a choice at one
point
like you were saying of either oh yeah
but i mean talking about being in a
society where that makes sense
like if we were born in the 50s in
suburban white america
and that's what you have to look forward
to though i think you would have been a
comedian i think people
uh no probably not i think people excel
in structure i don't think structure is
as limiting as some people think it is
and i think like having one woman you
[ __ ] for your whole life sucks in some
ways
but in some ways it's like really good
for you to be like okay i got that part
of my life figured out this is what it's
gonna look like i'm gonna have
companionship
uh
unconditional to an extent
wow partnership alison man i believe in
love and i'm a romantic
but here's the thing like
you can grow out of
like certain uh but but you're gonna
and it's not just like
[ __ ] the same person it's like
um
marriage do you think you feel marriage
makes sense like no
well i just think that we went from
monogamy to uh
corporate takeover and
poverty
male single male
male
[Music]
i've seen people be married and
be frustrated
uh sexually and otherwise and take it
out on each other not just my parents
like all across
where i'm from yeah so
it's like marriage and companionship and
finding someone and these are all great
like
thoughts but
uh
the applications have been uh from what
i've seen not very successful you know
what i mean
yeah
but i mean
what do you consider successful because
they've been doing monogamy for like a
thousand well
right successful i should say maybe
because if the purpose is to just
continue
an agrarian society yeah yeah and
control have more workers and more
dating
bodies to the slaughterhouse yeah
then yeah the system works you find one
person you make
a lot of children and then you die yeah
uh
but i don't know i've been uh i i kind
of don't want that
don't what i think we might romanticize
like oh it'd be nice to want that yeah
but that
ultimately is
the the life you
chose to not do
yeah
yeah i mean i don't think that's good i
think it's better to live in a community
and just [ __ ] everyone
and have like one steady or like one
mane well i don't know [ __ ] everyone but
at least be
uh
satisfied satisfied in that department
where you're not making choices based on
your how depraved you are and how
afraid society is to talk about sex yeah
like
like there's poverty and there's also
sex poverty
i don't know if that's real
yeah um well that's what they're saying
people
uh
that controls people's lives in many
ways and
uh it's not talked about because it's
like
it's embarrassing yeah
how much we need
bad vagina yeah
yeah
and how much it controls our lives
but then like why is it like
we're not meeting up like isn't that
frustrating because you know women all
they talk about is dating
and men all they want to do is [ __ ]
so like why is it not happening why is
like there's a fundamental like why is
what not happening problem with
like sex the people are [ __ ]
uh i mean not as much but it's like
i think uh it's getting like condensed
so people get very
i think that's why
when people do let it out
it's like uh they have to let it all out
you know what i mean yeah i mean people
who are repressed uh are crazy but like
that's a very
constant very real equation yeah
um
so
i think humanity finds a way to adapt
that's why
i think that's why [ __ ] is weird right
now
yeah
maybe we're getting sex when we don't
deserve it as a generation
that's don't you feel like you get the
exact same amount that you deserve nope
you feel like you deserve more yeah i
think it's really unhealthy
for a long time get more
but what if you're living in nazi
germany and you're a jew
you deserve to not have sex
because you happen to be a jew in
germany no that's let's say i mean
listen that's a very specific
example
there's a socio-economic condition i
don't think those like in in those
examples of extreme human
cruelty i think maybe those rules kind
of
go away
yeah well there's equations different
types of human
uh societies that we have to deal with
and just because you're in one doesn't
mean that it's
the i think that's why we don't like or
we collectively reject those kinds of
ideas and societies is because
we see the future of repression that
it's going to create and we
collectively
rejected i think yeah hopefully
i mean i don't think people are doing a
good job of it
yeah i think
there's certain nostalgia like
but but that's why i feel like
like everything is a [ __ ] cycle you
know what i mean like
like people hate the the traditional or
like it's all about the traditional
family and then the next generation
rebels against that and they're like
they hate that and then the generation
after that goes no let's go back to it
and it's really just that and
i don't know
yeah
i think we are evolving but i think uh
the cycle just repeats itself at
different evolutions
of us
yeah
um
we should uh we should do a better job
of like
appreciating
we're like a part of the spectrum
like we're heading somewhere we're just
like in a transitionary phase
where really the purpose is to not go
extinct right
so everything i feel like is about that
what
incoming transmission
incoming transmission
so uh incoming transmission what do you
think about
[Music]
that's your ringtone no oh yeah
that's uh that's really funny hans
why is that funny that's
you don't think that's funny is that not
why
you
made that choice
for someone to think it's funny
i don't know is it funny i mean i think
it's different i think it's weird
is it funny because it's like
you one of those uh
funny nazis is that what you are
i don't know i don't feel
like i find a lot of stuff funny
i don't feel like i'm a good comedian no
that's
i mean i don't know i feel like i'm an
easy laugh but
like
uh
we have low standards
so do you think that
it's better to do like sketches and
uh
you know
like um
like stuff like that
like uh filming stuff and like having a
script
or like as opposed to what as opposed to
podcasting oh i mean listen i think
everything can be done right
yeah i like sketches
do you uh
do you do sketches regularly right now i
wouldn't say regularly but
um do i do a sketch right now sure
what do you have in mind so let's say
that we're pretending we're roommates
because we got to work with what we got
we're roommates and there's uh you know
there's like an issue there's a girl
okay and you're like hey
there's a girl coming
i just need you to you know
kind of be cool and chill
and then it's like okay
and then she comes and then i'm like
being extra cool and extra chill
in a in a comedic way
you can't you can't
you can't just do that
that's a sketch in a comedic way
all this is done with comedy
sprinkle comedy
and voila
and this is where the humor jumps into
play
you should write that in the script
done with much comedy
make sure every word is dripping with
comedy
but yeah i mean
maybe like this roommate is like trying
to be cool
and really likes you but it's like
trying to withhold his sexual urges
or maybe he like really despises you or
maybe not despises you but just doesn't
care about you
and it's like going out of his way to be
like pretending he's not hitting on her
but hitting on her and actually doing a
bad job because he's a bad person um
how about a make it about like uh
like fries and coffee or something
why would that mean
like what's with fries why would that be
in an apartment i don't know because i
think like it'd be like that's very uh
like soap opera
yeah like like we can make like how
about uh
you're walking on me eating fries and
drinking coffee and like what the [ __ ]
are you doing that's
crazy combination
but i'm eating it
uh comedic
well why don't we have a bunch of
different things like you won't believe
what my roommate is eating now right and
just have like a tick tock
dude we have some weird [ __ ] here
yeah but then you'd have to eat it'd be
like a multi-day process
and then we would have to keep that
theme going and then i would uh
dive yeah then you just be doing it for
the bit yeah and i'll start eating
papers
well what about like what's a funny
situation that happens with roommates
maybe we could do a sketch about
that um
[Music]
what about when
your roommate
has
um
your mate has
like i don't know
a great big dane
there's trying to move it around and
i was thinking uh
maybe uh your roommate is fighting with
his girlfriend
or something
yeah i was thinking that's uh
the most i've laughed
yeah
like having the most ridiculous argument
yeah
yeah and you really get that perspective
of
listening
to an argument
but then like
why not just show a couple arguing
um what do we have to show you listening
to them because
like i feel like that's what where the
meta is is like you show the perspective
oh and then you're like what because no
one has a girlfriend but everyone has a
roommate who has a girlfriend so would
it be like a
single shot on your face
yeah maybe uh
it's just your face listening to stuff
yeah maybe you're playing tetris
and the the argument is happening in the
background
and the tetris kind of
uh
like
yeah so then what would they be saying
they'd have to be like ridiculous things
like well
i thought that
well yeah if you if you said that
why did you think the earth was round
yeah i mean
you're acting like jeffrey
didn't kill himself i said we have no
way of not knowing that it's not
flat
totally different
yeah that's where the comedy would come
in it's like all the different examples
right
yeah cause
would there be like a general
just like the man is wrong and the woman
is right
or that they're both wrong all the time
and
we should stop arguing as much or be i
was functioning individuals be wrong and
it would end in like the murder of each
other
or something
no never mind
um
yeah i was thinking more like uh like
they they're arguing but it gets to like
it it peaks and they're really added and
then they make up and they're back
together and they're fine type of thing
like that would be funny
yeah and maybe the roommate coming out
of the room every
now and then and checking in
and being like dude can you believe this
and then
it's just like the same cycle
yeah
maybe
man a lot of my sketches end in suicide
weird
all right
so uh
do you think that sketches are the way
to go or do you think maybe it's better
to just like well
again quality is whatever you can
produce at a high high quality i i would
say you because you find what you're
good at you know yeah or you find
whatever ideas uh uh
like whatever the best way to
translate them
yeah
i think that
it'd be nice if we had the
like uh the resources to give everyone
their own tv show and see what everyone
makes
um and i think that well isn't that kind
of what it is right now no no one's
making tv shows well everyone's kind of
making this like weird documentary eric
andre made a tv show
you know hannibal burris anthony justin
like had a tv show but like
people aren't just making tv shows
building on the street i guess he's a
comedian
i'm saying with um
really
recommending their own lives everything
i know but it's so low budget like you
need a budget you need to like be able
to execute ideas and like build sets
and uh
have nice equipment i believe in that
too i just honestly sometimes wonder if
i'm right
well don't you think that a lot of our
money is tied up in like the one percent
and so we have less money too yeah yeah
but we have less money to also feed
people and like
like have roof to groove like and fix
[ __ ]
yeah
it has many effects but one of them is
comedic one of them is uh the arts yeah
yeah
and
then we have less laughter less ability
to laugh less
happiness but maybe that's just an
excuse like
so that's why it's okay to like not try
yeah
but the good thing is like we have the
equipment to do like
low effort yeah because you would adapt
content
yeah because we'd be doing this anyways
we'd be probably doing something worse
than this right exactly so as long as
it's like a
positive thing in my life there's no
incentive for me to not do it besides
like
burning an audience
but you know honestly like if you can't
use an audience and you're just
preserving it
forever what's the point
[Music]
yeah you gotta
put it out there
yeah
i mean
you gotta like interact with the
audience instead of just being afraid to
um but yeah i mean i don't uh
i don't think that i'm doing a great job
of it but i'm doing more than i would if
i was constantly afraid of how i
appeared
but i would like to do more sketches and
like more
stuff that packs a punch
that can actually be consumed
in short intervals yeah i mean if
you feel it inside of you you want to
get it out you should make it
whatever it is yeah
so like with the boy
uh with you bringing a girl over and the
guys trying to act super cool
like what do you think would be funny in
that scenario
or if he was like uh like maybe the
guy's passive aggressive
yeah he's like but we all know how much
how how josh always does the dishes
he's always doing the dishes hey he's
like trying to do like roommate humor
but i don't yeah it just seems annoying
he's like around but
like
by the second she turns around he's not
there you know what i mean like yeah
he's being cool but barely like
she can barely not see him type of thing
[Music]
yeah i don't know if that's funny i mean
not your stuff my my premise um i mean
uh this premise is basically every
sitcom type of thing
whoa that's true
but you could like find a new spin on it
oh sure everything's been done before
yeah yeah sure
but i mean what uh what do you think
deserves to be captured or talked about
um
that's a good question man
deserves to be captured
maybe we could talk about like
um
dating in 2022
and finding out that someone's a trump
supporter
and being like oh
so
what do you think about immigrants
where do you stand on gay rights
do you think that we should fund
libraries
uh
do you like black people
[Music]
it's sort of weird meeting a woman who's
a republican because then it's like
you don't like yourself like you uh you
want to vote against your interests i
feel like a little refreshing it's a
little scary
yeah it's it's kind of scary but in a
good way like
maybe that's just like i like someone
who's like fighting for their rights who
hasn't just like completely given up and
just like i'll just be a good no there's
housewife like
like hey i mean again i don't uh want
i don't really want marriage or kids or
anything like that yeah my future but
so if it's not that but i feel like
uh
powerful
can come in any like there's some people
some women they're like no [ __ ] that
listen i don't need this whatever like
it can be it can be shitty but it can
also be badass i'll say that
yeah like ann coulter like candace owens
that's a little i mean listen
did it it's like they're fiery like they
have to like fight all the time they're
like
but i mean it's in a useless direction
well at the end of the day they're just
wrong
though like i don't think like they're
always
they're always playing a character
i mean yeah
it's like a tough exterior it's like
what they have to be to get their life
and they're like this is who i actually
am yeah i like who they actually are
their personality is the weapon they use
to navigate society
yeah
it's like pro wrestling i don't think
they're real
they're definitely not real
but yeah i mean they're like a kayfabe
or whatever they're like
putting on a front
but then like people who are authentic
will have an advantage and they'll
slowly out compete the inauthentics
so
it'll always be an incentive to be
authentic
until you reach an equilibrium but i
think like the
fact that we don't have enough money or
like
you know
that we we aren't in control of our
lives
and economically more of us are in
poverty than rightfully deserve to be so
i think that has the effect on the
dating and uh connections
i don't think anyone does but i mean
even if you thought some did like you
can't say that we're doing a good job
determining we should be in poverty i
think that we should just give food and
shelter to everyone
and hope they don't build a bomb and
blow you up right right that would be a
good reasoning to not
yeah
like hopefully they don't get bored and
just start going psycho i don't think
that'll happen
but
you just gotta [ __ ] you can't like
[ __ ] use that to make people do [ __ ]
for you i think that's really [ __ ] up
i mean if if you have to pay for that
[ __ ] like you can work to pay for room
and board
and that shouldn't be like 40 hours a
week
like i i don't know how much work it
actually costs to raise a human being
like that
i guess human beings are pretty
expensive animals
like if you have to take care of an
elephant
elephants are probably more expensive
yeah definitely
or if you have to take care of a dog
you probably less
yeah let's be less six
i mean it's like i don't know how much
does it cost to actually raise a human
and is that worth them working 40 hours
a week yeah i mean
you can you can you can do you can do it
on a such a low budget you wouldn't
believe
i know so it should be attainable
especially because it's like we already
have the apartments
and if they're all packed together then
it's easier to distribute resources
there's less transportation costs
well yeah it feels
so how much like it wouldn't be that
much if you if you really need people to
and you don't even need that because one
person can do the work of a thousand now
and we could really just have people
just chill we could just like give
everyone money
you ever seen total recall
is that with uh
schwarzenegger yeah
what happened in it
did he get his memory erased
yes yeah and then it goes to mars and he
releases oxygen
my point is going to be about like do
you think the future is going to be just
like a bunch of skyscrapers everywhere
with people living in them and a foreign
like housing that people that just
provided with a certain
salary like right that's that's what the
future is looks like yeah
because that's kind of i think about
that sometimes
yeah i mean
there's a lot of like
land
that's yeah just dead
yeah
well you don't need just land you need
like
it needs to be connected
easy to get [ __ ] to
[Music]
multiple ways so that [ __ ] and not a lot
of natural disasters
water helps if you're near water boats
boats are still really great
rivers
like chicago
railroads
but yeah i mean i don't know
it's crazy
we need to [ __ ] to feed and clothe
people and house them
uh yeah a
shelter food water uh yeah and then
from that's a good base you know what i
mean yeah
but that would require a mentality where
we're not invading foreign countries
well there will be no such things for
countries or countries
i'm just talking about the the immediate
near future yeah yeah so
i mean no i think we're going
like this is hopefully this is a way
i don't know it doesn't seem like
something happening sir
yeah
but everyone knows it's [ __ ] up
and everyone knows that it's sort of the
fault of capitalism
it's not like we're too communist the
problem is the money and the money is
all trapped up top
and the problem with
the reason why that's a problem is
because
people who get an advantage
get more of an advantage and then soon
they take over the whole thing
it's not a fair competition
i would love it if it was a fair
competition
but why would i play a rigged game
but yeah i mean that's why i do comedy
but
i don't know like
well i always feel like i feel like
comedy is a
good perspective to maintain on it of
being like just an observer who's
laughing at it yeah rather than having
emotional stake
in in the outcome i think that keeps you
sane
i think that's like the point of it
well i think it's like human to care and
to feel
i mean yeah you got to be like an alien
what about bill hicks or
george carlin
they were aliens
but they still felt everything they were
like
whatever i think that those what they
did worked
because they they gave a [ __ ] yeah i
think that was the underlying
thing
yeah
so you believe that they gave a [ __ ]
yeah
i think it's the same with like a jon
stewart and
kind of in a way louie
yeah
i mean you have to love humans i think
the species is strong
we should have more species pride
that's the only thing that makes sense i
mean nationalism is
just a limited version of that
and then i guess like
pride in all living life even though
it's not that impressive sometimes
but um
yeah i mean
just like the preservation of
consciousness and
sentience and the positive things in the
world
like i think that should be enough of a
motivation for anybody
and i don't think we need a god or like
a [ __ ] morality system uh besides
like
just positivity and
oh that's very ambitious
well it's the future like it's what we
don't have to believe in lies just
thoughts and blimps of light
yes
it's just gonna be positivity
well
i'm not just talking about positivity
i'm just talking about like
no harm it's just mathematical just
don't cause any harm
and uh don't cause despair
[Music]
that's like
that's like a
a part of ourselves but it's not like
the most important part
a nice point
but yeah i mean how long have we
i don't know
because it stopped what uh oh it did
it's 5 39 i have a show at seven so i
should leave in like 20 minutes do you
want to do something else sure what do
you want to do
i don't know
i was hoping we would watch the
the the dating
[Music]
we don't have to we don't have to
do you want to watch it and
comment over it
we don't have to i don't you don't seem
into it it's just like really funny okay
we can watch it
i'm just like i'm not
that interested in it but i'll still
watch it i'll i can watch it alone no i
want to watch it now because i'm like
interested in why i'm so reluctant to
watch it okay let's see if this uh
reveals anything
about you to yourself
i'm just i'm just too horny right now
and i don't want to like watch people
[ __ ]
this is just gonna frustrate you even
more yeah
well they're probably all right let's
let's not judge let's just watch
i like that
do you need me to move it um do you want
to that would be cool
yeah because it's all subtitled yeah i
can clear it
these are like the sexiest of the
sexiest koreans
okay
did i have my glasses
all right
you ready yes
this guy is great
[Laughter]
this guy is great
why is he working on shirtless put on a
shirt
no one lets you do that
korean guys are like so thin
like even if they work out
they're still like
they still got small frames
well
that's the future we're all gonna be
like that just that
body frame yeah like an alien
[Music]
this is like uh propaganda this is
that's how they want us to be work hard
for your capitalist overlords
[Music]
what's happening
she's so thin
she's so small is she like healthy is
that healthy in korea you think like
is how korean girls look she looks oh my
god
look at her being trying to be cute like
peering over her hair
like i can't even see right if you
wanted to [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
oh yeah her hair keeps far
oh my god her legs are like so
far apart
like even at the thighs her thigh gap is
ridiculous
but do you think asian girls are hot
what's up do you think asian girls are
hot
[Music]
like don't you think they're like the
hottest
i don't i don't think so i mean
but just like in terms of
don't you think like in terms of like
yeah like the average korean asian woman
is way hotter than any other because
they're all the same shape there's
the average might not be different but
the variance everyone is like
at the same level of attractiveness
i think you might have a point there
like more asians are attractive than any
other race
in terms of women
there's
not as many
asian women at least like here in
america
so
yeah
so there's always the exotic factor
yeah
why did he give her a pillow for no
reason
i think koreans are like
they're not [ __ ] as much as americans
are
they seem to be [ __ ] a lot
but they're like from an older culture i
don't know it does you think so
i don't know they all seem to be very uh
like i mean oh you mean on this show
right now oh no i'm just saying
in general they seem to be taking good
care of themselves and
if that's not to [ __ ] i don't know why
are you doing it
um
so i like cat face types
yeah i mean i think it's uh
i think you can like have a good body
but
i don't know that's not the same as
[ __ ]
it's just like a more repressed culture
sexually i think
you don't think so like no one's like oh
asian people always [ __ ] they say
that about like brazilians
and like french people
i guess i don't know
but uh but no one goes to the middle
east
for the sex culture is very repressed i
don't know yeah
do you think free would you say it's on
that level
no yeah yeah we're a little better than
that
i'm just saying like there seems to be
enough partying and like late night
well they're very americanized so i'd
love to see the rates that's what i'm
saying i feel like
that leads me to
uh
there's probably some [ __ ] going on
yeah
but i mean i just don't see it
i don't feel like
can't you imagine it
don't feel like these are the people
that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's sunny so they all have to
it's like get them an umbrella good god
they're all trying to be nice to each
other
are they gonna fight to the death
they don't know what to do all the
customs and culture
you know like they're used to going to
the bank and like standing next to
koreans and are like in an elevator and
they're trying to apply those rules of
their custom and like on this island
it's like why are we doing we're not
even there
it's just in their heads
yes
see like uh that doesn't i mean this
seems very uh at least they're
comfortable talking about stuff
yeah but you can exaggerate it for a
show
sure
this is taking forever
are they ever gonna do anything
well you have to get to know the
characters i really don't like
we're gonna have to watch it man
this is like the worst part of a party
is where you meet any everyone
and then you you cannot let's go to like
the third episode or something you could
just skip forward
dude i wanted to get to know
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is very interesting stuff
really groundbreaking
journalism right there honestly
i don't know man
i mean this is like fun to do
i am of course joking
but i guess it's like watching game tape
like when you're uh watching football
you're like trying to determine what you
would do would be best
and this is like that like in a social
situation how should you act
what should we do should we
should i have been more aggressive or
should i have
done something different oh yeah she
just expects the flirt
oh i hate it so much
and then you're just like not even
making eye contact with them
[Music]
and you have to hit on all of them at
the same time or they get offended
because everyone is hitting on each
other in this
it's like such a highly charged
environment yeah
you share it
dude it's so weird how they like they're
not not just [ __ ] right away
like it's just so frustrating it should
be a porn it should be like
an hour-long max
because it's like if you get a bunch of
bull elks and heat
and like female elks and then they're
just like standing around doing dishes
and like
you know playing hacky sack with each
other it's like why aren't you [ __ ]
i'm sure it's coming but you know
there's a dance they got uh
they gotta do a back and forth establish
yeah
oh look at the rice
but yeah i mean
it's like good to get to do that all the
pre stuff but that shouldn't be the
focus
[Applause]
and just the fakeness that comes from it
i'd rather be genuine and be like
we're [ __ ]
you have to be like oh see you're doing
the dishes there just noise
you're just like trying to impress
people
they're all in awe
[Music]
i hate it
this is so funny
and it's just a game it's like not even
about who's best but who can like appear
that they're the best
yeah man
this is the role of their lives i hate
it so much
[Music]
is there an elimination by the end of it
is it like a contest
[Music]
[Music]
oh
uh
aren't you wearing jewelry to bed
she's on a tv show
they always dress like this
so what's like the point of this do they
like get something it's like how many
but like does it cost them anything to
take put in the vote you only get one
vote
i think you can
[Music]
wow
oh my god
oh see the guy with the poem wins that
right
the weather was like here it's warm like
unless it doesn't make any sense
she's the weather man oh my god
all these hot girls have to be going
through rejection now for the first time
in their life she didn't get anything
she's like what was it what did i do
well
[Music]
ah she feels colder now dude
i mean they're all hot
they'd all be hot in whatever place they
decided to go
like the one wearing chanel and all the
jewelry
[Music]
i feel like a lot of like this is
supposed to be for people that you know
and if it's not
then it's like
i don't really care
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't give a
[ __ ] it's one of the g's geoenergy uh
oh what a show
what a show
i mean
it's a part of my life i do talk about
people like that
like like what like who's the most
popular girl oh this girl who's the most
feminine and who's like the most got the
most charisma as a man and
you know it's all interesting stuff but
it's like i don't know to focus on that
no of course not no this is for jokes
but uh that's why that's funny is uh
people being unapologetically
superficial
while
uh reasonable people try not to be uh
i mean i don't know maybe that's a
little elitist too but
that's why that's funny
is there like
they're just admitting to that [ __ ]
like
i mean it should be a thing like you we
should have like one place in the world
where we can just honestly talk about
social interaction since they're such a
big part of our lives yeah and most and
you know
on a level we are all
like
i just don't think that these people do
a good job of that i think they capture
like
uh
a thing about social interactions this
is fake but even that tells you but what
they chose to focus on
yes it's like hot people
i'm just saying even those choices
give you a little something
but wouldn't it be interesting if there
was an ugly person if it was like a well
cast of with like diversity with like
smart people and like if you look too
high handsome then there's a detriment
to that
uh just like an average group of people
and just like dating show
yeah or just like a living together show
like survivor
um i think in general i mean there's a
reason why actors and actresses are
beautiful
yeah i guess we like to look at it but i
feel like that's the part of us that's
the lowest common denominator that's
like yes
that's
true we can transcend
but it's like like what are you you're
you're you're better than your dna is
that what you're telling me
i mean everything's dna even the
intellectual parts
[Music]
yeah i mean i don't know i think i think
it's like i never felt like i'm a part
of this
so i get bitter and jealous
right
right that's very honest yeah because
you're like
this always seems stupid to me but it's
partly because i wasn't in it yeah
my brain is not even working though
i need to start working out
um
we want to
do something else this is fun
what do you want to do